hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Saturday as this is one of the
most epic matches in chess history this
is Paul Morphy versus out of Anderson
1858 and this is game nine of the match
like I said in my previous video you've
seen that casual game between Murphy and
Henderson more feet travel to France and
while he caught some serious case of
intestinal influenza so you know he
wasn't really in top shape but
nevertheless he insisted that the match
takes place and the first match the
first game of the match was won by by
Anderson the second game was drawn and
the well then after those two games
Murphy probably got better and got used
to Anderson style and he won the next
five games and the final result of the
match is well the match took 11 games
morphe won
Murphy won seven games Anderson won two
games and two games were drawn so I will
show you this game as this is my
favorite game that Morphy want and I
will show you a game that Anderson won
that's the next game game 10 of the
match as well Anderson probably probably
understood that it wasn't a very good
idea to challenge morphe to an open
tactical game so in in the game Anderson
won he opened the game with 0.283
and the first move so it was quite the
game and it was a very positional game
or it took all the way to the endgame to
defeat Murphy but like I said this is
game 9 and Murphy has the white pieces
we have E 4 and C 5 the Sicilian defense
but instead of night to have three more
feet immediately goes for D for the
Smith Morra gambit we have C capture
sandy 4 and down Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 Anderson doesn't really want to go
into this gambit so they transpose into
the normal Sicilian Knight captures on
d4 we have e 6 and now Murphy plays
Knight to b5 it wasn't really provoked
with a point to e5 move but more if he
plays Knight to b5 the same variation d6
by Anderson and now Bishop to f4 already
this is more sick
and the Morphy is attacking this d6 pawn
three times with the knight bishop and
queen so really provoking anderson to
push a five which he does anderson place
a five and be sure to eat three was
played and now well Anderson plays f5 a
very modern approach to this opening
maybe a six was a was a well probably a
safe approach here but okay
he played f5 and well morphe isn't
really worried about f captures on e4
and as you will see morph isn't worried
about f4 as well as more if he plays
Knight B tonight B 1 to C 3 allowing f4
which enters in place he plays f4
although this was a bit too much there's
really no point in well Morpheus already
developed and you're playing f4 losing
another tempo just to win the bishop on
e3 more if he plays Knight to d5
offering a bishop sacrifice and well
it's interesting that even if Anderson
didn't play this f4 move if he played
something like a six more fee would
still play Knight to d5 and after this
tonight is captured Bishop to b6 now
with the tempo on the Queen and after
the Queen moves Knight to c7 check
winning the rook so a very interesting
but okay
we had f4 Knight to d5 and here Anderson
captured the Bishop F captures on e3
morphic plays an IB to c7 with check
King to f7 and Queen to f3 now again
with check Anderson covers up Knight to
f6 and here Morphy plays a silent move
but a deadly move Bishop to c4 and now
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries after this Knight moves and
well what do you play here Anderson
played Knights to d4 now threatening to
capture the Queen and f3 and also in
some variations Knight captures on c2
which check some more if he played
Knight captures on f6 now opening up a
check from the bishop on c4 so the Queen
cannot be captured yet d5 by Anderson
and more few plays at Bishop captures on
d5 and this is well this is the
definitely the critical moment in the
game Anderson has a couple of options
here
he can play King to g6 he can play King
to e7 or he can play Queen captures on
d5 so let's see this Queen captures on
d5 idea if Queen captures on d5 well
night capture 75 and now Knight captures
on f3 g captures on f3 he captures on f2
with check King captures on f2 and rook
to b8 because the rook was attacked and
I ate and that worked at b1 the material
is about even
I mean Morpheus a pawn up and even
though Anderson has the bishop pair he's
completely undeveloped and the Murphy
has well an item c7 and the knight on d5
and both rooks are ready to jump into
the game on an open file so a much more
preferred position for white
so after this Bishop captures on d5
check another option was to play King to
e7 and this was in fact the strongest
move although Anderson played King to g6
if King to e7 this would actually be
playable for black because after Queen
to h5 threatening Queen to f7 check and
also Queen captures on e5 would check
Anderson has this resource of playing G
captures on f6 now this F pawn defense
a5 and he does allow Queen to f7 but
this doesn't give white really anything
after Queen to f7 with check King to d6
there is no way to continue the attack
for white as now this night on c7 is
attacked twice and after Knight captures
an a8 and Knight captures and c2 would
check for example King to e2 and now not
capturing the rook but Knight to d4
check and well depending on what more
people would play here it would be a
very playable position for black in fact
but okay this never happened as after
Bishop captures on d5 check Anderson
played King to g6 and this allows Morphy
to execute a move
well Queen to h5 with check forcing
Anderson to capture the knight on f6
King captures on f6 and now well this is
a great opportunity for more feet
make a mistake for example nights do v8
with check it seems like a really good
move but it actually loses completely
Anderson could capture the night wink
actress sunny eight and if Queen
captures a Bishop to b4 check now
opening up a discovery from the rook to
the Queen and after c3 rook captures
Queen on e8 and black is completely
winning here but of course Murphy wasn't
gonna make a mistake like that after
King captures on f6 Murphy plays a very
a very nice move F captures on III would
attempt on the night and with a deadly
threat of kingside castle would check so
here under some play tonight captures on
c2 with check Murphy played King to e2
and in this position the German master
resigned the game as whatever he plays
well he's completely lost for example
the most obvious move will well Knight
captures on a1 what happens here well
rook to f1 would check and dr. King to
e7 Queen captures on e5 would check King
to d7 now Bishop to e6 with check King
to c6 now rook to see one with check
king b6 and queen to be 5 with checkmate
this is pretty straightforward but after
King to e2 you don't really want to
capture the rook as your well your king
is getting hammered here for example
let's fry Queen captures on c7 removing
one of the attackers out of the attack
if this was played then again rook 8 to
F 1 with check a king to e7 and now rook
to f7 and well the queen is lost but not
only the Queen after King to d8 rook
captures on c7 well capturing the Queen
and also attacking the knight on c2 and
after the King captures rook then rope
to c1 pinning the night and well there's
simply too much material for white so
this doesn't work as well
another approach maybe after this King
to e2 by Murphy instead of resigning
would be to play g6
but this also losses on the spot
rook a to f1 with check and for example
King to g7 now rooked
seven would check King to g8 only move
and now Rock to d7 with checkmate
blocking the bishop and now this bishop
on d5 delivers checkmate and even after
this rook a to f1 the King doesn't go to
g7 if for example Bishop the f5 was
played even this has a crushing
continuation rook captures an f5 with
Czech and after G captures an f5 Queen
Queen goes to f7 with check King to g5
and now Knight the e6 pushing the King
further and winning the Queen although
the Queen doesn't have to be taken it's
for it's a forced checkmate but you know
you don't want to play a position like
this so understand understood all of
this and after more if you play King to
e2 anderson resigned the game and yeah
definitely definitely a beautiful game
my favorite game by morphe in this match
and well even though anderson said after
the match that he wasn't really in shape
but okay i mean morphe also wasn't in
shape he was drained by leeches and you
know he didn't really have the full
amount of blood in his body but also
anderson said that even if he was in top
shape that mr. Murphy would probably win
this match either way so yeah a great
game by morphe and also a great showing
by mr. anderson resigning in such a
position not going for any prolong means
i hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here i would
like to thank vas email Hussain in Iran
John Raghu Ramon Rica show and of course
Tony more guitar thank you a lot I
really appreciate it and I will show you
the game were Anderson beats Murphy as
he does play a three and the first move
and it's well it's it's quite a victory
for him as the match was already lost
sir thank you for watching and I will
season